President Trump has a warning for
America's allies he is once again
hinting at a radical change in the way
the u.s. supports NATO of course minor
Kevin cork has more on that from the
White House
Germany is paying 1% of a much smaller
GDP we're paying close to 4% of a much
larger GDP so I think we should pay the
same as Germany to the denizens of the
Palmetto State it was music to the ears
President Trump talking tough about NATO
calling out Germany for what he says is
its lack of financial commitment to the
Alliance and suggesting now may be the
time for the u.s. to pull the purse
strings it's all wonderful and we like
to help out but it helps them in Europe
the president's critique that members
aren't doing enough to fund their own
security is not new he slammed the
alliance on Twitter warning that change
is coming a message sharply delivered to
NATO defense ministers in Brussels and
received a loud and clear at the White
House more and more allies are up to 2%
of GDP for defense but they also agree
that we have to do more NATO has 29
member states but only 8 countries
including the u.s. spend the agree to 2
percent of GDP on NATO in fact at 3.5%
of its GDP the US accounts for 22
percent of NATO's total budget many of
America's largest partners like Germany
fall well short prompting the
president's threat to match their
spending levels senior administration
officials say the president's rhetorical
pressure isn't likely to be backed up
with immediate policy changes but the
risk for the alliance is all too real
particularly for European capitals
who've watched warily as Russia invaded
Ukraine and annex Crimea in 2018 when
the numbers are finished we'll have the
largest increase in defense spending by
our NATO countries outside of the United
States
since the Cold War the rhetorical
pressure by the president is seen by
some as a proxy issue for what he
considers unfair European trade
practices something which will get a
great deal of attention at next month's
NATO summit in Brussels Brett
Kevin cork at the White House Kevin
thank you